joined by my colleague Jade warshaw
we're here for you to shower America
it's a free phone call to jump in Triple
Eight
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five Jade
looking fabulous as always today I try
Ken you you sir are looking quite Dapper
yourself all right very nice enough of
the niceties you're trying to help these
finds do it let's do it let's do it
Marissa joins us in Annapolis Maryland
Marissa how can we help
hi um I just want to say thank you for
taking my call
um I just want to make it known I'm
brand new to all your teachings
literally last night I was gifted by two
my really good church friends with a
financial piece and um I actually just
got set up for
um George's class that's great I just
had my phone
You're Gonna Love George by the way it's
gonna be great so we're glad to have you
on the show what's going on
yeah so
um my question is how do I zero in on
the type of job I should be looking for
and just to give a little background I
just graduated with my Master's I have
an undergraduate degree in communication
studies I got my Master's in
community-based Education and Leadership
and I just feel like I have no idea what
opportunities I should be pursuing or
what opportunities would fit me okay
well I think we need to pull back from
opportunities first
because that is focused on what you see
directly in front of you and that can be
very intimidating let's just talk about
why you got into that direction because
those are very very specific areas of
opportunity connected to those Majors so
is that the space you want to be in the
type of work you want to be doing
I mean yes I I'm honestly pretty open to
anything which is hard even going into
college
um I was a student athlete I played
softball
um in college and
going into college I was still super
unsure of what I wanted to pursue when
it came to education but
in Communications in the master's
program I um
did I did enjoy it and I see myself
going into that direction for sure okay
well the reason I ask is I want to know
how passionate you were maybe about a
problem or a group of people attached to
a problem because all work
is either solution based or desire based
in other words I'm giving a solution to
a problem or I am meeting someone's
desire and so what you've got to do is
is when you're looking for ideas and how
to pick a direction it all needs to be
connected to
two specific things one is what is that
problem or desire that's connected to a
people group that I go I want to work to
be a part of
that and then secondly where does my
unique talent
my abilities to come in and be a part of
that problem that's where we ideate and
I just have done this so much I got a
feeling Marissa that you have a couple
of ideas that are at the top of your
mind they kind of float up there
whenever you think about what is it that
I really want to try is that true or
false
that that's definitely true all right
give me give me the top one or two
so I would say the first one is I want
to be able to help people
um that voices aren't typically heard
um whether that's high school students
college students whether it's more the
older generation I just have a passion
for helping people at any sort of
circumstances all right now let's be
more specific okay when you said void
their voices aren't heard go deeper go
couple level levels deeper and don't
worry about how it sounds it's just me
and Jade okay
what are the problems of those people
what what has happened to them what is
their circumstance that pulls your heart
in be more specific you can give me a
couple examples if you want
yeah
um so once again being a student athlete
um I feel like
a lot of people have their own like
stigmas or their own perceptions on what
it is to be
um an athlete whether that's high school
college professional whatever it may be
and I feel like a lot of the times
yes our voices can be heard a lot of
times they're overlooked
um whether that's with
um
well for my personal experience
academics mental health stuff in that
area
um
so this is coming from your own Journey
yeah yeah for sure and um so who helped
you who helped you overcome some of
those challenges mindset stuff academic
stuff maybe a coach overlooking
something you didn't feel you were
getting a shot who helped you
yeah I would definitely say the people
in my community when it comes to like my
church
um definitely one of my closest friends
her name's Kylie
um she actually pursued me into knowing
who Jesus was and that definitely set my
the base of my life and
um how it overcame a lot of things when
it came to being rooted in Christ so I
would say
um through that or good my mentors
um when I did this I was a part of this
group called young life so those were
the people that helped me the most so
here's what I'm hearing and the times
where I needed it so what I'm hearing is
is that you've always had an interest in
communication you're probably pretty
good at communicating you're certainly
good on the air but you have the ability
to connect with people and if I went and
talked to people who know you really
well they would say Marissa's always
been good at connecting with people
she's good at communicating and I think
you have a heart for people who feel a
little bit lost a little bit down
they've got some self-worth stuff going
on whether it be mental or emotional and
and you want to be that guide to help
them see themselves as they should see
themselves and believe in themselves and
overcome that hurdle that's what I'm
hearing how does that sound to you when
I repeat it back to you
yeah I would say that's pretty spot on
all right so I'm sitting next to a
former Dean one athlete who competed at
a high level okay and and the reason I
want to bring you in here Jay just
because I I want to hand the Baton to
you because I see
a potential coach that we're talking to
a teacher a guidance counselor maybe a
therapist I see the heart of a coach
regardless of the profession what are
you hearing what are you seeing I agree
it almost sounds like you want to come
in and be sort of a liaison or some sort
of a a counselor for a team or for a
group of folks
um and I'm not exactly sure what that
look looks like I don't know if that's
you coaching a team and you just have
those qualities that you offer as a
coach
um and it's just part of who you are as
a coach or if it's something where
you're approaching teams and saying hey
um here are likely some problems that
your teammates are facing I'd love to
come in just do a little workshop do
something to where you're meeting those
people where they're at and you're
offering that value
um to the team as a whole because a
healthy team is going to be a more
successful team so that's really
interesting I love it so Marissa I've
got a homework assignment and a gift for
you the homework assignment is I want
you to seek out a teacher or any level I
don't care what level a guidance
counselor a therapist counselor coaches
and I want you to spend time with them
and talk about the ins and outs of what
they do what they love what they don't
love uh and just see what your heart
begins to select and I think that's the
process you need I'm going to give you
my book The Proximity principle which
will help you with that specifically and
then my assessment to get clear
assessment you need to take that I think
it's going to further help you to find
some ideas thank you Marissa you're
you're an athlete you're a champion
believe that you're gonna find your path
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life
specifically your money your work your
relationships here on the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by Jade
warshaw this hour the phone number to
jump in is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five so we
have people tuned into every episode of
this show and they all know the stuff we
teach about money but they're still
feeling stressed out
stuck behind that eight ball of debt if
you will why because knowing what to do
with your money isn't enough
you have to do something about it
personal finance is 80 behavior and only
20 head knowledge and The Proven way to
change your behavior
is by taking Financial Peace University
this class is different
because
um we all we we we we walk you through
the step-by-step interactive way to win
and it's the difference between trying
to get in shape on your own versus
hiring a personal trainer you'll have a
coordinator holding you accountable and
other people in the class cheering you
on that's why this class has worked for
millions of people after nine weeks
you'll never handle money the same way
again don't just listen to the show
commit to doing what we talk about on
the show to win join an FPU class at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's
ramsaysolutions.com FPU I think I'm like
week five or six uh coming up Wednesday
night uh it'll be uh less than six
actually uh class that I'm coordinating
you just wrapped up another class I did
and I know George is George he's about
ready to start okay so very fun personal
trainer there you go
that's the only time I'll be compared to
a personal trainer all right we'll just
leave it shoot your shot Ken thank you
thank you Jade Avery's up next in
Philadelphia
Avery how can we help
hey um thanks for taking my call I'm
sure I feel like I I have a kind of
unique situation
um and I listen to you guys regularly so
I might have an idea of where we're
gonna you know what you'll say but
basically I have a student loan
um student loan debt that's 17 and then
I had just bought a truck and I have a
car loan that's fifty thousand so
right now I have no interest on anything
um because the car loan I'm paying it
off I'll have it paid off in four years
and there's zero interest on that and
then the student loan because of the
student debt stuff with Biden and or
whatever
[Music]
um that's there's no interest there
um for now yeah for now correct I have
all I have the money in the bank and I
can pay off and be debt free today why
don't you um
so there's no interest and the next
thing I want to do in life is is buy a
house
um so the money that I have in here I
have all that money in the bank
yeah but you're not gonna you wouldn't
buy a house while you still have all of
this debt laying around right
that feels like a recipe for stress
yeah so my kind of my the reason I guess
for the call is because there's no
interest it's not costing me anything I
guess there's no interest occurring on
sure it is you know on the debt what's
your combined payment on the truck and
the student loans
uh the trucks 1100 and then the student
loan yeah all right so that's 1400
that's what it's costing you it's
costing you fourteen hundred dollars a
month in payments that's what it's
costing you
and it's costing you right now to have
to choose between paying off this debt
or doing something you really really
want to do which is buy a house it
sounds like so that's what that's the
cost right there
so okay so your move would be go debt
free today
um and that would take my you know and
I'd have money to survive obviously but
no no bro so so exactly you would have
fourteen hundred dollars more per month
in your budget
the minute you pay it off you just got a
fourteen hundred dollar a month raise do
you not understand that
I yeah I I understand what you're saying
so let's walk let's walk it through so
you can kind of understand the method
behind the madness because I know for
you you're like these people are crazy
let me tell you what it means okay so
you said you got the 17 000 of student
loan debt 50 000 cars and what what was
the third debt
there's no third debt okay it's just
those two and how much money total do
you have laying around in savings
um also I want to know about
non-retirement Investments do you have
anything like that
um so basically
um for the the investment I put in
um 500 a month towards like a Roth IRA
okay that's retirement investing do you
have any non-retation I'm just trying to
see how much cash you have laying around
or uh money you can get to
no I don't do any
um other investment other than that okay
so how much total cash do you have
sitting around
um basically so if I did it all I would
have like 10 000 left over no how much
cash right now do you have sitting
around
I think it's like say seventy thousand
dollars
seventy thousand dollars look at that
she must Raise Your Voice she almost
raised her look no I'm excited because
you're gonna be debt free yeah okay
you've got sixty seven thousand dollars
of debt and you've got seventy thousand
in cash which means we're gonna set
aside right off the bat here's what I'm
doing here I'm working through our baby
steps
so I'm setting aside a thousand dollars
right off the bat just as a just quick
emergency fund it's not the be all
end-all it's just for a moment because
you're going to use the rest of that
money to pay off your debt and then
you're still going to have two thousand
dollars left over to put to add to that
savings so that over time you can make
it three to six months of savings and
think how quickly you're gonna stack
that up because you just cleared up all
of this money in payments fourteen
hundred dollars a month in payments
you've just cleared up so think how
quickly you're gonna stack back to three
to six months of emergency fund maybe
you want to Stack back the 70k I don't
know and then after that we're going
into baby step 3B which is saving for
that down payment for a house now with
all of your income cleared up no more
debt you could save this up so fast and
then you go into home ownership and it's
like I can breathe I don't have this
debt weighing down on me who cares if
it's zero percent interest it's still a
weight you know tied to your ankle right
what do you think about this Avery
well yeah I I'm it's kind of unique and
I've now long time listener and uh my
dad and I you know he got me into Dave
Ramsey and all that
um I I guess it's like the way I look at
it and this is why I wanted to get your
perspective is because there's no
there's no interest it's not costing me
look look it is it's costing you 1400 a
month Avery all right let's go back to
what let's go back to where Jade left
off you've been listening to us for a
long time so you know what the baby
steps are yep but Ken the problem is he
wants to keep this debt of course well
he wants yeah he wants yeah he wants the
safety of the house he wants all that
right now Avery if you want to keep your
debt we can't help you
you're scared
to let go of the 70 000 or 67 or
whatever it is 68 right now and only
have two or three thousand dollars in
your emergency fund but listen how many
months is it going to take you to save
up three to six months expenses what's
your take home give it to me real quick
um I work for myself so it kind of
depends but just say roughly I'm
bringing in so I make a hundred thousand
dollars a year okay great okay so three
to six months of that if with this new
fourteen hundred dollar raise you're
gonna give yourself as as Jade walked
you through this you're gonna be able to
save up for that quickly then you have
nothing to worry about you have a very
healthy immersive but then you save for
the house but you've still got all that
margin Eleven Hundred Dollar truck
payment on a depreciating asset someone
has sold you uh what is really just bad
math about well it's zero percent
interest you're getting this money for
free but your truck is depreciating very
quickly and you're paying eleven hundred
dollars a month for four years and you
think that's a good plan
versus versus what four to six months
you get in your emergency fund where it
needs to be yes or no
honestly look at the look at the basic
math of this if you have seventy
thousand dollars of cash but you have
sixty seven thousand dollars of debt you
don't really have seventy thousand
dollars of cash it's fake money correct
it's a fake feeling of you know it's
just that basic uh balance sheet right
at the end of the day you got three
thousand dollars to your name that's the
truth of the matter and that's the thing
that you need to focus on you don't have
seventy thousand dollars Avery you got
three thousand dollars
the money is costing you almost fifteen
hundred dollars a month
oh that makes my stomach hurt I'm gonna
pause for a moment get some passing AC
do commercials and we'll be right back
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
Hollow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman joined by my
colleague Jade warshaw and uh special
special guest who gets two specials if
you were watching the show right now you
see a very very cool looking handsome
stud uh to my to my uh
and you're thinking Ken would never ever
be able to hang out with somebody like
that in real life some might call him a
snack again oh really yes I feel very
weird about calling him a snack I'll be
honest
Jade's better half I don't know if I'm
supposed to say that either the first
time I've ever been called it because
you're on the show No One Believes for a
second she's a better half but I believe
you can call him a snack yes I can but I
on the other hand I'm gonna stay away
from that uh but he's in here for a
reason and you know we've been we've
been hearing from you the people about
this economy that we're in where people
are making more money but Jade you know
this things cost a whole lot more money
inflation has been stubborn those
grocery bills uh everything bills
today's prices are not yesterday's
prizes that's exactly right and so what
we've seen Jade as a result of this is
we've seen the gig economy which is a
new way of saying the side hustle
economy maybe I drive a little bit of
uber I do some delivery I do a lot of
different things we're seeing the
freelance economy for white collar
workers but I'll give you one example
maybe a programmer who can obviously do
some high-end programming they're
getting contract work through freelance
because companies are uh not as excited
about offering a full-time salary when
they can get you at a contract level so
all that said the side hustle is a big
search engine thing right now people
want to know what can I do how can I do
it because I want some extra money and
so we were talking about this and and
this guy to my left uh he's a stud in a
lot of ways but you guys figured out the
side hustle thing and he's got a really
cool gig as a side hustle so I wanted
you to set that up and then I'm going to
ask him how he got there because I think
our T our audience can learn something
from him yeah people want to know how to
do this and you know a lot of folks know
our story we paid off 460 000 of debt
and that wasn't just with our you know
day-to-day income we did a lot of side
hustles and our Mantra early on was
instead of going now I'm not poo-pooing
this because you do what you got to do
but for us instead of going out and
doing the Ubers and the doordashes and
the instacarts we were like I feel like
we can take our skills and make more
money doing things that we enjoy doing
that are already
um a commodity for other people we can
offer services so it was anything from
dog training to Sam was designing
websites and both of us were teaching
lessons I did voice lessons Sam Did You
Know piano and guitar lessons and um out
of that came this idea that hey like we
can set our own hours we can make money
and in during the pandemic you know
everything was shut down us being in
Entertainment Earth thing was shut down
and uh Sam came up to me he goes hey I
know that we're watching every dollar
right now but
do you think that we can arrange for me
to pull 170 out of the budget because I
have a side hustle that I want to invest
in
and I'm like oh boy you know
everything's shut down I'm like you want
to do 170 For What and he's like Jade I
want to sell I want to resell Jordans
sneakers if you're over 50 tennis shoes
if you're I don't know if you call them
shoes basketball shoes sneakers sneakers
thank you oh sneaker still works for the
youngsters that is what that's what
you're calling it yeah tennis shoes as
well I'll show you how oh so I flipped
it yeah you flipped it yeah it shows you
how in touch I am with the youth so so
what'd you think when he first throws at
I want to resell Air Jordans and Jordans
and all this stuff look I'm not Sam can
do anything like he's he's not a guy
that lets you down like he's a person
who even if I don't know how to do it
Jade I'm gonna figure out how to do it
so when he said that at first because
money was
funny during the pandemic I was like um
at first I was like I don't know but
then I was like you know what it's Sam
yes that's all you did yes you just said
in Sam I trust and Sam I asked questions
okay no I was like come tell me when you
make some money well right but I love
that you didn't ask a bunch of questions
like What's it gonna cost what's your
margins she didn't do any of that but
yeah he he said he was sharp so okay how
did you get the idea this is what I want
people to hear how because you were
doing lots of different things and it
comes to you all right I I want to do
this I think I should do this okay let
me back up I didn't come to you with the
idea in 2020 I came in 2019 the end of
2019 and and I'm saying this because
this could get awkward I don't know go
ahead because in 2019 I I came with the
idea I said hey I need 170 bucks I just
want to try this yeah and I I bought a
pair of Jordans for retail and I sold
them the next day for nine hundred
dollars I made like 750 bucks it just I
couldn't believe it I was shocked and so
now fast forward to 2020 you know for
the next year or 18 months I I kept
trying to do that over and over
basically like win the lottery okay and
that's not how it works and one day Jade
and I were talking and she was like dude
you're trying to be
the hair not the tortoise and I realized
that I just had struck lightning one
time and then I really need to figure
out how this thing actually works and
that's when I really got into it but now
were you why did you initially like the
idea
um I've just it's one of those things
when I was a kid I love Jordans right
and I figured if I want to buy Jordans
what's a what's a better way to buy them
without spending like right your own
normal budget money right then resell
them yeah so instead of house flipping
you're a Jordan flipper yeah that's what
you I mean on the side for fun right so
okay so now we've got the right timeline
yeah all right and so now she says you
need to be the tortoise what did that
look like so that looked like me going
to uh so
I had like 800 in this account that I
had made I piddled it all away trying to
right figure out other things what that
looked like once I decided to be the
tortoise I basically had 170 bucks again
I go to Nike outlets and I'd buy
anything that there was a profit
marginal even if it was like ten dollars
yeah if if I I told myself if I can make
a 10 profit on this shoe I don't care if
it's five dollars that's a win right and
if I can make five dollars a hundred
times that's five so then you just
started doing this started stacking the
money and started the money out yes I
figured it out the hard part the
discipline is you can't spend any of
that money you just have to keep
flipping it keep flipping it
um until you do have profit until you do
have profit that you can pull out of it
you know to right the news and the more
profits you have then you could buy a
little bit more expensive shoe and then
have higher margin exactly so then I
stopped going to the outlets I started
going to the retail stores and you know
a lot of people what you'll see online
is a lot of people are trying to um
uh basically win these draws right I was
going to the mall doing the hard work I
went to the mall every day for 60 days
straight so give me a percentage what
kind of margins are you making now on
Jordans
it just depends on the shoe but well it
also depends on your customer because
that's a big part is using your network
yeah proximity principles kicked in big
time so yeah I went for coming to you
yeah I got a lot of people coming to me
and you know we're musicians so I got a
lot of artists and athletes pro athletes
and stuff coming to me and so those
shoes have a bigger margin so I can make
100 or 200 percent on that you guys mind
can we share with the audience what kind
of money you're making on the side just
in this when he within them within a
year of him doing it he was putting
about five to five to seven hundred
dollars on the budget every month when I
started like when it picked up once it
picked that life so I said about it what
are you making now so on on a on a good
month
um I mean it varies I don't push as hard
as I once did because this was
sustaining us through covid but uh five
to the most I've made in a month is
seven thousand dollars
flipping Jordans folks
that's over eighty thousand dollars a
year for those of you that need a
calculator uh that's unbelievable money
so uh here's why we brought Sam in I
wanted this audience to see and hear the
story here's what it started out with
something that he was interested in he's
a creative guy but he wasn't designing
or doing this he just simply going I
like shoes I like the kicks I think
there's margin here and he began to do
it on a disciplined level after he
figured out I'm not gonna strike gold he
stayed with it he's now built a
reputation and a clientele yeah and he's
figured out the fine print on how to do
it right we could go into deep detail of
how you find the shoes where you find
the shoes okay which one so here's what
I want you to hear the takeaway from Sam
warshaw is if you want to have a side
hustle that you're willing to stick with
and be disciplined pick something that
you really enjoy you'll stick with it
through the ups and the Downs as you say
that's true 100 you stay excited about
it
it's 80 000 plus dollars flipping
Jordans don't tell me yeah
it's not alive and well my goodness
that's not a side hustle that's a dream
job for some of them I love it don't
move we'll be right back this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
talk about your life specifically your
money your work and your relationships
I'm Ken Coleman joined by my colleague
Jade warshaw we're here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five Jade we hear this I feel
like every month when we get together in
our production meetings we have new
people joining us at enormous rates and
high numbers YouTube and podcast numbers
are going bananas and and welcome to all
of you who are new you've stumbled upon
a video or you got a podcast
recommendation and you're here and
you're going to hear things like baby
steps and then the the individual baby
steps gazelle intensity and rice and
beans and beans rice you're going are
these people nuts well that's still up
for debate but if you're new to the show
we want to get you caught up on the
money conversation that we're having
where you fit in these seven baby steps
that we teach that will get you to True
Financial Peace and Freedom and so we
have a site of ramseysolutions.com
that's our main website
ramseysolutions.com and you see a get
started button there and just click on
that and just in a couple of minutes
we'll get you caught up and and you'll
see where you are on the journey so that
you can join in the conversation and
always know that we would love to take
your call we're here to coach you to
encourage you triple eight eight two
five five two two five Hannah is up next
in Dayton Ohio Hannah how can we help
hi I just have a question
um about regarding if my husband and I
should keep our frontal property we
lived in it for three years and
um it's a duplex and now we bought our
own home so we're just trying to see if
we should sell it or keep it so the
duplex do you have a mortgage on it
we do how much is it
um a one
um 124 000. 124k is what you owe on it
uh what's it worth do you know what the
units would sell for
um we can probably get about 200k out of
it okay
um
and your car you said you've got a
second home you've already bought
another house or you're thinking about
buying another house no we already
bought
oh okay
um
and you've rented out both sides of the
duplex at this point
um we're not quite finished with closing
yet on the other home so we are still
living in the duplex for right now until
it closes okay and what's the mortgage
on the new house
um it will be
um 327
wow and how much cash flow are you
getting from the duplex or
um do you hope to get from it
so we have another renter lined up um
when we close
um so she'll start in August and we'll
get 2200 a month
um
you know if it were me in your situation
I probably would have sold the duplex
and taken that money and rolled it into
the brand new house just so that you can
go in with a massive down payment I mean
you'd pay it off super fast because you
wouldn't have any other payments what's
your income
uh not including the duplex rental
yes
um 130 yeah
I mean if you're asking do I think you
should sell the duplex I'd probably
get rid of it so that I could be debt
free with my home even sooner you have
any other debt
no just just some mortgages
yeah you know for me I'm every decision
that I make is one one that's going to
get me closer to financial peace and for
me I'd probably get rid of this duplex
it's cash I mean the cash flow is nice
if you can maintain that but would I
rather have 2 200 a month or would I
rather have a paid for home that's worth
four hundred thousand dollars and I
would rather have the paid for home
that's worth four hundred thousand
dollars then I can sell save up I can
buy more real estate down the line in
cash
yeah that's what I've been thinking but
everyone has been telling us we need to
keep it we need to keep it and we could
have it paid off and because all they're
seeing is monthly income all they're
seeing is you're making 2 200 they're
not seeing the debt and they're not
weighing that into their calculation the
risk of that because all it think about
it all it takes is something to go wrong
with a renter a renter not paying
somebody moving out somebody just you
know breaking their lease there's so
many things then you've got the repairs
to think of now you've got two
properties that you're maintaining both
carry debt and it's going to be so hard
to cash flow all of that not resort to
helocs not resort to credit cards but
when the property is paid for you don't
have that desperation where it's like
I've got to get a renter in here right
I've got to get this fixed so yeah
that's what my husband and I have been
like thinking I'm like because we have
our car in case like a car Fund in case
uh one of our cars does get put we may
not you know if something happens to
rental then that our car front's gone
and then we would have to resort to
loans in that way and see you understand
it so Hannah Hannah you and your husband
are on the same page that you should
sell the duplex
our real our realtor says we won't I
don't want to sell your rental property
can you get a new realtor get a new
realtor listen yeah and you can all the
pro you can there's always properties to
buy all right there's always
the side you want to get into this later
on it's going to be there
after that look well there'll be other
houses to sell and buy you'll be all
right right I know I know it just sounds
like a hassle like we are 25 and 26 and
we want to travel and yes okay what's
the duplex worth
okay and what do you owe on it again
124 so we could profit about 50 to 60.
how much would you love to get an
infusion of 50 to 60 thousand dollars at
this point in your life
listen listen
it's you and your husband's life it's
your budget it's your dreams it's not
and if no one else gets a vote
so stop worrying about what everybody
else says and what they're going to
think and by the way I'm not getting on
you here I'm trying to set you free
to do what you two believe you should do
because you know it's right and Jade and
I are agreeing that you guys are right
it's the right decision financially and
it's the right decision for you to
emotionally and where you are at stop
worrying what other people are going to
say your friends and family and your
realtor when you decide to do what you
want to do it doesn't matter what they
think and oh by the way once you tell
them what you guys are going to do then
they'll just shake their head roll their
eyes make whatever snide comment or not
say anything at all and then they'll
move on to their life and they don't
care what you are doing so you should
stop caring about what they think you
understand what I'm saying yeah
absolutely the new cycle on that is
going to last 10 seconds and then
everybody's going to go back to what
they were doing before they're gonna go
what Hannah and them sold their duplex
that's true and then they're gonna go
eat a chicken sandwich for dinner that's
right just like that tell your realtor
that he or she has 24 hours to get a
sign in the front yard of the duplex or
you're going to get a realtor who will
sell it
yeah yeah yeah that's it that's right
there Ken who wants to Commission on
this I know right and we forgot rolls
here Hannah Hannah you've got good
instincts you and your husband have good
instincts do what you know to do pocket
that 50k hey if you don't have any other
debt in the world you can roll it into
this house you're gonna be debt free
before you know it call us back matter
of fact come down here and see us come
on in the lobby when you pay that house
off it's just reframing actually they
didn't need reframing she and her
husband are on board it's just the power
of peers I think this is so important to
talk about people that we we really like
and love those would be your friends
family yeah and then you got people that
you respect like a realtor who's been
good to you and they're a pro and
they're the pro yeah they're the
professional they can sway us it's funny
I mean I think that when it comes to all
of this stuff can money managing your
money getting out of debt how you're
managing your money the best Freedom
that you can have is when you stop
caring what people think when it's just
like hey
my neighbor can go fly a kite if he
thinks that I should be renovating my
house he can go fly Cod I don't have the
cash to do that right now you know the
guy at work he's been asking me yeah
you're still driving that jalopy right
he can go kick rocks right you know what
I'm saying you got to stop caring what
these people think and uh that's when
you hit that tree that true Freedom yeah
well you know it's just reframing to say
that wait a second what we've done with
this duplex is really really smart we
sold it and we're taking that cash and
putting it down on our house our first
home yeah which now we don't have a
nuisance if we want to travel we don't
have to worry about some Rancher calling
me up going uh the faucet is stuck right
that's not even a phrase by the way I
don't think faucets get stuck but but
they're tied down when they have that
that property they they're not going to
go travel around the world for months on
end
Hannah Hannah do what you and your hubs
want to do you guys are right so fun all
right Jade good hour thanks as always my
friend for being on the show with me
she's so good and uh thanks to James and
the entire crew for keeping us on the
air America this is your show this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Jade warshaw this hour
the phone number for you to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five eight eight two five five two two
five we'll start it off this hour in
Champaign Illinois faith is there Faith
how can we help
I just graduated high school I was
rapatorian oh wait a second Faith I'll
just skip by that I know real slow clap
for Faith the valedictorian ladies and
gentlemen very nice congratulations
thank you so my parents I've known you
guys for 10 years my parents have
blessed me and teach me everything by
Dave Ramsey and so I'm not touching that
at all I'm gonna get close to it I know
the whole situation so I dedicated
myself to getting
scholarships and I got
plenty enough to get a full ride wow no
I don't have to I don't have to worry
about college
and so you're like a unicorn yeah really
so um now I'm working just because you
know I love working I enjoy it and I'm
trying to make as much money as I can to
have a good future
and so I was wondering what do I do
should I start investing or what should
I start doing I have a thousand saving
savings and almost a thousand in
um my checking account and then I have
extra money on the side like some other
stuff but I was wondering you know what
you guys recommendation for me because
I'm typically baby step three but yeah I
was just curious on what I should do
well first off you're a freaking rock
star girl you're killing it I mean
valedictorian she's working she's got
scholarships got an emergency emergency
phone got a little more cash we don't
know how much cash he's got stashed in
the backyard I mean I want to meet your
parents number one because they did some
things right you know I'm saying they
raised you right very very good
um very very good
um how much are you making uh right now
working so I'm a waitress so it's not
guaranteed but I make about
um 60 to 100 a night depends like
tonight I'm gonna work and I'll probably
make almost a hundred and then whatever
I get per hour I get 725 per hour okay
so very cool probably a night for just
that but yeah so about 100 I'll probably
make tonight and then yeah I mean you
could definitely start looking into
investing I think that that would be
great
um in your case probably just like a
Roth IRA because you you need earned
income to put into that
um but yeah I I totally would start I
mean your baby step wise and even you
know we've got a set of baby steps that
we have for Young Folks basically that
they follow and you followed all of that
you know having five hundred dollars
saved and you know paying for college uh
debt free paying cash for a car you've
done all of that
um and so yeah you are at the point that
you could start you know as long as
you've got that earned income you could
start investing and if I were you I'd
probably go ahead and start because look
at 18 years old the amount can
we've got to talk about this at 18 years
old that compound interest is going to
be kicking you know what I'm saying
we've got and you know so many people I
just have to talk Faith so many people
they don't get to start until later in
life and I'm not mad at them they're not
doomed in any way they're still going to
be all right but you starting at age 18
is amazing because what you're going to
be able to accomplish
um most people are not even going to
ever be able to catch up to what you're
going to be able to accomplish because
of the time that that interest is going
to continue to compound you're going to
be I mean how much do you think you
could put away I mean would you be able
to max out
you know 6 500 in a year
um yeah because last year I had about 10
000 and then I hope my parents do
something so I gave them some money
because we're looking to pay for our
cars because we're we flip cars my
parents do that and we also have a
business so I help them with that
um we've affordable business so I know I
love the entrepreneurship and I have
some questions about that but I won't I
won't belabor it so you giving your
parents the money
was that a car for you
yes so yeah okay so it's just how ping
for a car because when I was 16 you got
to get one and so now we're selling it
and I'm gonna buy because they kind of
help me pay for it like I paid half day
pay fast okay so you're not you're not
giving them money for their side
business
all right our red flags went up for a
second we're gonna go ahead and pull
those back out okay so um yeah well so
what I try to do is when they have their
business that's me like I don't want any
money from them because that's what they
feed me they house me that's me helping
them
so what this is going to look like is
you I would bring my parents in on this
because it's just a great thing I would
check out one of our smartvester pros
and I would sit with one of these ladies
or or gentlemen and they're going to
have the heart of the teacher they're
going to answer your questions they're
going to let you know what your limits
are what you need to make what you can
contribute and they're going to help you
they're going to help suggest ideas of
how to invest this money of course
um with Ramsay Solutions we suggest four
different types of funds and they're
going to go through all of that growth
growth and income aggressive growth
International and they're going to help
you say this is where we this is what we
think but they're not going to force you
to do it they're just going to walk you
through that and of course at the end of
the day you don't invest in anything
that you don't understand and you can
take your time and you've got your
parents there and this is just I think
this is a really cool opportunity for
you to learn it's a really good
opportunity for you to just start
exercising that muscle of investing and
again smart investor pros come on can I
can't talk about that enough these folks
know what they're talking about they're
vetted they follow Ramsay principles and
a great experience for you Faith to sit
with them and let them
teach you to where you understand it get
your mom and dad's input but yeah you
could put as much as 500 bucks a month
in at the rate you're working you're
such a rock star you got some money
saved as well so you can max out that
6500 uh I think pretty easily and I just
think that's wise if you're my kid and
you're in that situation I would
absolutely say do it really proud of it
you are an overachiever my goodness I'm
just thinking back to when I was Faith
as age Faith's age and I feel like a
loser I mean I've got some definitely me
too you know what I mean I'm like man I
thought I had it together oh man I was
like Dude where's my car I was not on it
Dude Where's My Car oh my gosh all right
so let's talk about so here's a young
person who
has has figured it out I think she said
she'd been listening to the program for
10 years yeah and good old mom and dad
and she's figured it out she's busted it
you're talking about on paper she is set
up beautifully valedictorian full ride
all of these things but these young
people are still getting
uh an enormous amount of bad information
dubious advice from Instagram Tick Tock
commercials as to what they should be
doing early on with their finances and
you can get in a trap at 18. well yeah
just credit cards yeah or feeling like
oh it makes sense to take out student
loans and all of a sudden before you
even understand what you've done you've
built a financial trap yeah I mean I
think their intent is right I think that
young people are seeing okay debt has
affected my parents I've seen the way
debt can affect things and I think that
they want to get ahead I think they're
interested in Building Wealth but
they're looking to social media Tick
Tock and sometimes they're getting the
wrong information it's a good intent but
a wrong strategy so I'm glad that she's
got connected with Ramsay and we're
going to teach you the best way uh the
safest way and the most strategic way to
build wealth fast that is a fact don't
go anywhere a few messages and then Jade
and I will be back here on the Ramsay
show in Duke
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague Jade
warshaw excited to have you with us the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five time
for our question of the day today's
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
now if the weather is warming up it's
time to enjoy your outdoor space
neighborly's mosquito Joe service can
help make your outdoor area pest free I
gotta call them today I saw a mosquito
last night on my patio that was big
enough to carry a toddler away so I I
need to get this service we live in the
Southeast here where like they look like
birds oh yeah they eat sub sandwiches
yeah it's not fun uh so if you want to
be outside and enjoy uh your outdoor
experience without getting bit by a
mosquito mosquito Joe services for you
this is just one of the services at
neighborly.com where you can reach your
local mosquito Joe today all right
today's question comes from Brandon in
New Mexico he says I work at a job that
provides wealth for my family but I'm
not passionate about it and I feel
exhausted how do I balance pursuing what
I'm passionate about with the
responsibility of providing for my
family I feel that if I leave my current
job other people will see it as
irresponsible and they wouldn't
understand why I'm willing to take a pay
cut for a little while just to get
closer to the career I love and that
lines up with what I want for my future
and my family wow interesting love this
question Brandon and you've got a false
choice
and this happens a lot the choice that's
lined up in this question is
do I pursue what I'm passionate about
which might take a short-term pay cut as
as a reality of a step to move forward
towards the life that I want that
includes what's good for my family work
that I really find meaning in or do I
stay in a job that pays really well and
this is a false choice and the reason
it's a false choice in the way he's
worded this way and brain and why you're
positioning this way is because you are
more worried about what other people
will say than what you believe
in other words you believe it's right
to take this other job you've already
got it in mind it's as clear as it can
be to me or it's another Direction it's
been very that's been made clear to you
and so it's a false choice because you
are worried about what friends and
family will say
because you're walking away from
something that's prestigious and what
looks like a step backwards to them is a
step forwards for you and it's not their
job to understand it it's not your job
to make them understand it you could
certainly explain it but it's your life
it's your future your family's future so
in this situation I'm I'm okay as long
as we can budget for it yeah and we can
plan for it we don't want to make this
move and put ourselves in bad financial
straights there you go but if we can
sacrifice plan make some life changes to
absorb what would be a small pay cut or
a significant pay cut I'm okay with if
we can absorb it and we're not miserable
in resenting the decision six weeks in
so this is the idea here
um we gotta we can't just do the heart
the heart tells us and now the brain
helps us figure out the plan that's so
good and let's do some common sense with
this but I'm okay with this and I think
again it's a false choice you must
choose
to to take the path that is purposeful
and it purpose isn't just I was created
to do this kind of work it's this is the
lifestyle that I believe I'm supposed to
live for my family we are not just
occupational people we are relational
people and we spend I mean we spend so
much time working and at our jobs if
you're not doing something that gives
you energy that you enjoy doing that
feels purposeful man that's just that's
no way to live it's like and in your
family Union your family unit like if
Mama and Papa ain't happy no ain't
nobody happy oh that should be a pump or
sticker that's good let's go to Dustin
in Orlando Florida Dustin how can we
help
hey what's up Ken how you doing guys
we're having a blast what's going on
with you how can we help yeah so my uh
major question is is it immoral or
slightly wrong uh to go back to school
um using my GI bill
um and then throw the money that I get
for my housing allowance for that uh to
throw that at my baby step too
is it unethical
what do you think well well I don't I
don't know is it the GI bill or the
housing allowance part it's the housing
is the housing allowance uh from the GI
bill
um so a little bit of Back info
um
make around uh 70 to 80 000 a year
um you ever take a look at it I make uh
on my 90 disa disabled uh so I get
um my money from my VA disability
which covers my mortgage and my
um everything housing allowances and
stuff currently but um I'm looking at
going back to school uh looking at
getting a business management degree
um
because I do I do love the job I'm
currently in
um after uh getting out of the military
I was reading your book
um and it was like really you know gave
me like okay like yes this is going into
this job field that I'm currently in
um what I really wanted to do okay uh
let me jump in let me jump in really
quick because I want to make sure I'm
understanding this right I got a little
confused so you're in a current job
right now correct
yes what are you doing and what are you
making
actually a roller coaster mechanic
um
um make about uh 75 okay all right so 75
000 is a roller coaster mechanic and
then what is your disability payments
that you get for your service in the
military
so my disability payment is
um
right around uh
21 uh 266 a month that's part of that I
counted that into that uh oh it's a part
of the 75. yeah so I kind of counted
that as oh okay so why wouldn't you use
why wouldn't you use your disability
income to pay off your debt and use the
housing allowance for your house
I mean yeah it's just kind of I mean
it's moving funds from one board yeah
and I'm questioning why are we going
back to school do you want because you
just told me that my book helped you
pick out this mechanic job do you really
want to go into business
well um just like with
um it would still be basically just to
move up and to progress in the company
um going from being the you know the low
level mechanic uh moving up into you
know supervisor
um okay here two things number one you
don't need a uh what was the degree you
were looking at uh business management
you'll need a business management degree
to move up in management
if you're moving if you're in mechanics
that's number one I'm not telling you
not to do it I'm trying to figure out
the math on this deal
so if you go get this business
management degree are you doing it part
time
uh yes I would be um trying to pull as
much time as I could
um with working I worked nights uh 40
hours a week
um but I work 410 so I'm off three days
a week okay that now we're starting
those three days okay so you could pull
this off without being fried is what I'm
hearing yeah yeah okay uh because I
heard disability I'm just trying to make
sure all this is feasible here because
this is all about hey should I go to
school so that when I go in back into
school you're going to get a housing
allowance from from the government
correct correct and what's that
additional housing allowance going to be
2 000 a month
and oh go ahead no no that's right I was
going to say so my screen says is it
unethical to use my GI Bill to go to
school I want you to explain to me why
that's why you feel that's unethical
I'll be honest it's not my forte of
study but why do you feel like it might
be unethical what's the part that's
hanging you up and I can we'll try to
help you with that part
um I guess this for me is partially like
um is it because you can pay
I mean uh so I mean my my work
um also does a tuition assistance
program but knowing that I could take
this GI Bill and
essentially get this degree for free and
also it would it would help me
um essentially by the end of the having
the degree would get me out of baby step
two and babies
the housing allowance to then pay what
he's saying is I'm getting housing
allowance which I don't need can I use
it to pay off debt and I think the
answer is yes yeah I would say use the
to use a housing allowance to pay for
your housing and then that frees up
money in your budget if that makes you
feel better to do it that way do it that
way yeah I mean you don't need the
degree but if you want the degree you're
getting it free thanks for thanks for
your service you've earned it you've
earned it uh so there's nothing
unethical about doing this at all uh I
think that's his big hang up well I
don't need the housing allowance but I
get it anyway but hey I put it towards
paying off you know what he currently
has I would use it it's an allowance
whenever I got an allowance I did
whatever I wanted with it that's the way
I look at it there's some wisdom this is
the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
talk with you about your life
specifically your money
your work in your relationships all
three of those areas
are interconnected and if you're not
winning in one of them it tends to
affect the others and we want to help
you I'm Ken Coleman joined by Jade
warshaw the phone number for you to jump
in on the conversation is toll-free
Triple Eight
825-5225-88-825-5225 let's go to Lori
who joins us now in Sacramento
California Lori how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call
um I'm 61 years old thinking about uh
setting myself up for my retirement and
um I have about a thousand dollars at
the end of every month and I'm wondering
am I better off putting it towards my
mortgage or putting it into investment
so you have are you totally debt free
totally debt free awesome so and are you
currently investing 15 percent
uh no right now I'm only investing the
match at my 401k okay so following our
steps what I would tell you to do is
invest up to 15 of your income that's
baby step four
right into your retirement and then
anything above and beyond that we would
put on the mortgage to pay off the
mortgage how much do you have left on
your mortgage
about two hundred and thirty thousand
okay are you still working
oh yeah okay perfect well yeah how long
do you plan on working
until my mortgage is paid off okay nice
so what is 15 based on our baby steps
what's 15 of your take home
good okay so what's your let's see
what's that fifty fifteen percent number
of your take home roughly
I was thinking a little bit more than
that thousand at the end of the month so
um at this stage Jade are we putting all
thousand in there I think we are yeah
you want to get to the 15 percent
I mean and if and if I'm if I'm putting
rather than putting the the extra into
my 401k that's kind of what I was
thinking should I put it into a Roth
instead after tax and and uh or does
that matter at my age so yeah the way we
do the way we teach it is
um match beats Roth Beach traditional so
if you have a match on a traditional
401K you could invest up to the match
and then you could move over and invest
in a Roth IRA and Max that out and if
you still had money to go you could come
back
to your 401k and continue to do that as
as far as you can make it until the
match
or until the okay until the limit I
should say does that make sense right
right yeah that does I I did want a
question I did want to ask a question
though because we do find this sometimes
um are you finding it difficult
to have 15 left over to invest
no okay
I just wanted to check
you know for a really long time I've
been living
uh beneath my means and I've always
saved at least 10 percent uh off the top
and then right now I'm putting 25 away
in but it's my ish account so what's
that like 12 000. that's that's my my
fake emergency fund
okay but what you call it she called it
an ish account which I love I'm gonna
put that in my pocket for later it is my
ish account so you know I should give
putting 25 away for the last you know
five or ten years
so how much is in the ish account
only about 12 000 right now hold it hold
it hold it okay I'm gonna dig deeper so
you've been putting away 25 of your
income from for that long and you've
only got twelve thousand five hundred
that's not that's not an emergency fund
that really is an ish account it really
is an issue account so that's you that's
just your slush fund like whenever I
feel like doing something I go I go to
that account right right I don't know I
think okay that's cost you a lot of
money
well I mean I didn't do too stupid of
stuff with it I didn't like buy a car or
I should get a house remodel okay out of
that account okay well this is easy that
shoot up a huge so this is easy you're
going to be able to put the full 15 in
because you're just putting less money
into ish
you know that's what you do you pay cash
for renovation she's been disciplined
uh-huh although I just I want to make
sure it's I feel like it's been a little
too much because she could have been
investing that money yes yes but in the
grand scheme of things there's a there's
enough discipline for you to now fully
fund baby step four and never stop what
do you have in investing what do you
have in retirement so far
about uh 325 000. okay yeah let's let's
keep rolling with it what's the house
worth
the house is worth about uh maybe 550.
there are we okay yeah yeah when we when
we get to the end of this you're gonna
have a million dollars that's exciting
but yeah let's let's swap it instead of
doing 10 into retirement and 25 into ish
let's let's get those balances right and
like Ken said you've got you've got good
habits it's just making sure they're
like going down the right lane and so
now we're focusing on investing and
you've got three to six months of
expenses saved for emergencies correct
correct okay and then like let's you
know if you've got sinking funds or an
ish fund for whatever you know of that's
coming up but here's the thing if
there's nothing coming up that money
that's sitting there in ish can be good
put to good use Well I this is where I'm
gonna go I I'm sitting here listening to
this Lori and
um it's not going to take much for you
to put the full so let's take 1500 bucks
okay you've already got a thousand in
Surplus we play around with those
numbers even pouring into ish and then
deciding to take back out of ish and
we've easily got the 1500 a month to get
us to baby step four now we're rolling
now here's the deal you could juice that
a little bit for a while right and not
put the money in the ish account right
you could do a little bit more but you
could pay off that house I'd like to see
the payoff the house because I I'm
asking you if you weren't if you weren't
putting this money into the ish account
and you were putting it on the house how
many years ballpark do you think it
would take to pay off the 230 on your
house
I think eight years
love that I mean that's good that's got
you at uh below the age of 70.
and you are a millionaire
plus plus
and and just anybody who's listening if
I wasn't so ish I would have been done
and that right there that's the mic drop
moment that's what we needed to hear is
that's it you know you got it you're
gonna mess around and find out if you
don't get on it and and do these things
do the right thing with your money early
on yeah but the good thing is sounds
like she's the good news is Laura you've
got this you just got to decide what you
want more I think this is a priority
issue and I think it's just you sitting
down and going where do I want to be 10
years from now and what decisions allow
me to get there quickly look I'll take
an ish account over debt anyway of
course I just thought that that's what
she called it that was so fantastic I
love that I absolutely love that all
right let's go to Hannah and Salt Lake
City Hannah how can we help
hi I am curious on how to start a hard
conversation with my parents about what
to do with some money that they're going
to come into I kind of have an idea of
what they want to do and I just don't
think it's the best thing for them
um so how do you have conversations with
parents about about money girl look when
you figure it out you come and let me
know because
look
it's hard it's hard and I don't know
I'll be honest with you I don't know
that it's always
our place to do that and if if we do see
you don't say like if we do see okay my
parents are not making good decisions
and you want to step in
I
I admire that and I applaud that but
they're grown folks and it's very very
hard for parents to take advice from
kids Dave calls it powdered powder butt
syndrome and it's it's basically like
they raised you and then you're coming
in saying hey I think you should be
doing this with your money like what are
you worried about
it's true misbehaving they they're well
they're 52 and they've been broke their
entire life
first time they're going to have any
positive money yeah and it's going to be
roughly about four hundred thousand
dollars so Hannah here's the deal Jade
is right we're running into a commercial
here's the thing I think that you can be
clear with them about the opportunities
instead of tell them what not to do why
don't you go and go hey I'm so excited
about this windfall of money here's what
you can do can I help can I coach can I
hold you accountable suggestions not
Corrections clear and kind is the best
shot you got this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Jade
warshaw we're here for you America
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so the job market and the economy
are in a weird place right now we hear
all these different things
jobs are being added but unemployment
spiked
uh interest rates still going to be
jumping up a little bit we're told and
yet you know uh
uh inflation is kind of Dipping a little
bit so you get all these mixed messages
it's a weird economy and it's uncertain
and so that uncertainty causes people to
just freak out and so a lot of people
looking for jobs opportunities in new
cities or states want to get that job
maybe before the economy goes into
recession all these things people are
speculating and that's going to involve
thinking about moving and starting a new
life in a new place which can be
exciting and intimidating but you can
take a lot of the uncertainty out of
that part of the equation when you
partner with a local expert in your new
area someone who'll show you the best
neighborhood schools and places to eat
but seriously you need someone who's
invested in helping you start your new
life on the right foot in a place you
love and can afford we're talking about
a real estate agent but not just any
agent an agent who'll do more than find
you a home but connect you
uh to the right place for you and that
is a Ramsey trusted real estate agent
they're local experts who go above and
beyond
to serve you and you can trust them to
guide you if you want to connect with
Ramsey trusted agents all over the
country who are ready to help you buy
sell and hit the ground running in your
new home you can find them in your area
by going to ramsesolutions.com
local agents that's ramseysolutions.com
local agents you want to know what I
loved about my Ramsay I would like to
know I'm going to tell you real quick
when we said this is the price point
that's what she showed us she wasn't
trying to get us
that's it that's all I wanted to say I
like that there was no angle no it was
just serving how is the new place loves
it love it the warsaws are settled love
it and and yes we love it we love our
house our realtor incredible yeah I see
her on my morning runs in the morning oh
that's nice that's nice really really
great there's some extra accountability
you know you don't want to sell somebody
a bad house and see them jogging it's
not a good look no it was great we got
exactly right she understood when we
said hey we're doing this this no credit
you know we're doing it 25 percent like
she understood all of their Ramsay
language that's what you need all right
there you go folks again uh if you're
new to us these are men and women that
we have vetted and we hold them to a
high standard of service that Jade is
talking about or else they're out so
again uh those new to this check them
out
ramsesolutions.com local agents all
right David is waiting for us in St
Louis Missouri David how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call today
you bet
um my wife and I should finish our fully
funded emergency fund just at the
beginning of this next month and we've
been saving that just in the traditional
savings account with a quarter of a
percent interest and I know that a lot
of people use the high yield savings
accounts online with like betterment and
Marcus and things like that and I just
wondered if that's something we should
consider because I'm not sure how I feel
about having it with that extra degree
of separation where there's not a bank I
can walk into I actually what you're
seeing as a con I see as a pro
um obviously you're getting a higher
interest rate when you're going with
some of these high-yield savings
accounts I use Ally there's a lot out
there Marcus there's betterment yes
um and I actually like the fact and I
actually suggest the fact that you make
your savings account at a separate
institution and that you make the three
to six months money a little more
difficult to get to I mean obviously
you're not investing that money you want
it to be you want to be able to get to
it liquid but with those accounts yeah
it's like you have to transfer it over
to your bank and that might take a day
which is not a bad thing because it
gives you that's right it makes you
think through do I really need to pull
this money out of my emergency fund and
I actually think that that is a great
degree of protection
um just especially depending on your
temperament if you're the type of person
who really struggles with keeping your
money separate and not touching it it's
good and for some folks I'm like hey
don't even get the debit card like some
of those savings account they're like
and we'll send you a debit card I'm like
why do you need debit card on your
savings account you need to just when
it's time if it's time transfer just
what you need into your account and
you're good to go that's why that's my
take on it Ken well I agree with you
that's what station I have so our
emergency fund is in a high-yield
account that is takes 24 hours so you
can get it and by the way any emergency
it can wait 24 hours you're not going to
be up a creek without a paddle yeah
you'll be fine you're fine and you're
exactly right and we do that because we
just and by the way we try to cash flow
small emergencies yes all right let me
tell you something when you fully get
into this plan and you really Embrace
baby step three you don't want to test
your butt off for that when you have to
dip into that I get cranky I had to get
on myself recently because uh you know I
got teenagers and that means cars oh and
you know a couple thousand dollars I'm
sitting there looking at I was like
I had to get on myself you know why
because I was moping around the house
you're getting in it cranky about
pulling money out of my emergency fund
and I should have been like thank you
Lord for my emergency fund but I was so
cranky about having to dip into it they
were like Ken you got money you need to
chill I know that's why I like to leave
it over there I like to look at it and
go oh there it is so David do you see
what works do you see what we're saying
here David I do I do
um I kind of have a piggyback question
off that real quick okay we can do that
yeah we got a strong back
now uh in our primary checking account I
usually like to keep ten thousand
dollars in there it could be always be
able to start off the month with that am
I doing Overkill with that or yes I'd
just be with the emergency fund too I
mean how much what's your income
um well this last year was 115 but this
next year it'll be a little less because
my wife's finishing her graduate degree
yes it's Overkill it's Overkill applaud
your discipline but man you're too
scared yeah you need to you don't need
to start off with 10 grand you get okay
do you have any debt let's go back no
let's go okay so there's no debt here
you need three to six months and
honestly depending on your situation and
this is for anybody listening we say all
the time three to six months of
emergency well Jade can how do I know if
it's three months or six months it's
really dependent on a couple of uh
criteria that you can look at how stable
is your income if you're married are
both of you working do you have stable
jobs if so three months is good do you
have good health are you in and out of
the hospital a lot maybe that's
something you need six months because
you're doing deductibles and things like
that if you're single and it's just one
income maybe you want six months because
it only takes one thing to knock out
your paycheck these are the things that
we're thinking of so for you figure out
what's best three to six months and
that's it
put it in a high yield
put it off to the side and then you're
in baby step 3B if you're trying to buy
a house and after that you're investing
take that 10K you better put that in an
investment account and let it work for
you instead of losing money sitting in a
checking account due to inflation you're
just losing money on that 10K
does that make sense to you it does I
just like having that accessible for
this for our regular budgetary expenses
if you're not careful what it'll cause
you to do is not stick to the budget
because you'll go oh we've got this 10K
sitting here so we don't really have
it's almost like
and I use this lightly but it's almost
like you could apply the credit card
mentality because you just got this net
of money sitting there just like a
credit card would you go well I don't
really have to stick to my budget
because there's just money sitting here
David do you ever use it for that
in other words how often do you find
yourself dipping into that 10K cushion
because your budget's off
very rarely dude you're so tight you
squeaker
you don't you don't even use it man and
listen I'm I'm not making fun of you I'm
like dude I had a feeling
that he's never touched it I can I just
tell you something I think it's a
healthy dose of fear and what I mean by
healthy dose is you're responsible
because of that fear but to Jade's point
it's actually limiting you and I think
you need to let go man you got the White
Knuckles out you need to let go man and
use that 10 grand better you feel me now
I do love a cushion I do love a cushion
but that's too much hey yeah that's too
much he needs to chop that down by by 90
I think you need to take about 60
dollars of that and go get you a mall
massage he's elusive not in the mall
come on those guys do a great job they
really do so you're the you're the one
who I passed by in the mall getting a
massage no shame face down drooling on
the floor mall massage there you go
fantastic this is who he is America
that's a fact folks you'll thank me for
it later she's Jade warshaw I'm kid
Coleman this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we talk with you about
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman Warsaw joins me to shower the
phone number is toll-free for you to
jump in so that we can coach you and
encourage you triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to Chase who is joining us on
the line in Austin Texas Chase how can
we help
um so my question was
I was in debt at one point use the baby
steps
um got out
um actually sold pretty much everything
and worked good jobs where like you work
and where you work you live so like
Resorts and stuff so you're pretty much
able to stay in your entire paycheck I
was able to get out of all that Consumer
Debt
anyways now I'm in school
um and I'm fortunate enough I've been
able to pay for the school and I've
chosen to take on additional student
debts that I don't need at zero percent
interest
and I'm putting it into CDs
so I'm getting four and a half percent
on it but it's liquidable
um and so I was just curious is that a
good idea or is that is it just that
always bad I think it's a bad idea
um you've got debt now and you've got
the risk associated with it
why wouldn't you just take your own
money and invest it in mutual funds and
get a 10 rate of return
and then not carry any debt
associated with it
so I'm I'm doing a little bit of that as
well not in mutual funds but I'm putting
money into a private Equity debt fund
but it's it's liquidable as well like a
mutual fund but the student loan because
it's in a CD I mean unless they're they
they're not FDIC insured I don't think
they can collapse so my question was
like is that it looks like I'm carrying
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
Chase I'm interrupting because Jade
asked you a very good point-blank
question didn't answer you sounded like
a guy running for congress so that was
good I'm very smooth how you redirected
but why answer her question because I
think you called us and she answered
your question with a question and so her
question is basically saying yeah okay
you're getting four and a half percent
which you borrowed to get that why not
do what she just said if you're doing it
a little bit over somewhere else why
wouldn't you do it across the board with
this money
I know the answer well I want him to
answer why I wouldn't put it in a mutual
fund no my question is here here's I'll
answer the question that I asked you for
you you want to get rich quick
that's why
you that's why you're borrowing money
that honestly is supposed to be used for
education and you're putting it in CDs
of all things which if you were gonna do
it I'd say at least go all out and
invest in a better vehicle but it's like
betting on a snail the point is you're
trying to get rich quick and that's
going to lead to Folly because there's
no such thing as get rich quick it it
doesn't
it doesn't work out and if it does
honestly you're just lucky it's not
because of common sense it's not because
of Good Sense and we're seeing that more
and more we're seeing uh YouTube and
Instagram and Tick Tock crazes where
it's like Leverage there is such thing
as a good debt and when you use it good
it's called Leverage and those equations
never equate for two really important
things a they never equate for risk Ken
they always assume that everything's
gonna go right everything is going to be
perfect and they never account for
something that here at Ramsay Solutions
we think is so important and that's
peace
yeah if I'm getting if I'm gaining
wealth I want to have the piece that
goes along with it I saw a tick tock
where the girl was like I've got six
million in debt but I've also got 9
million in assets
and I was like how do you sleep at night
like that just that doesn't hit right
for me and here's the thing
you can do what you want to do you're
grown
um and you you can choose to listen to
the advice on this show or you can go
another route we're not mad at you but
if you call into this show we're always
going to teach you
um
what we believe is the best fastest uh
path to wealth and that is to pay off
your Consumer Debt it's to take your
income which is your biggest wealth
building tool and to invest it into good
mutual funds over time and we've done
here here's the thing here in Ramsey
Solutions we have done the biggest study
of millionaires ever done
and in that study we studied what do
millionaires do what is the practice
what have they done over the course of
time that has allowed them to build this
wealth and you want to know what the
answer never is
I took out student loans and invested
them in a CD at four percent that is
never ever ever the answer not to
mention I just don't think it's right
would you love for the the student loan
company to know or the government was it
government or student or a private loan
well God please not private Chase uh no
no no no it was so I qualify based on my
income yeah but who is government
subsidized I'm essentially using my
income to put it into CVS if you because
it does go directly to the payment yeah
you are very talented at mental
gymnastics yeah and this is just not a
good idea it's not good investing
strategy and it's not what it's intended
for so that's our answer again you're
going to do what you want to do on this
but you'd be much better off investing
in much better vehicles with your money
yeah so you still owe the money pal I
mean at the end of the day oh yes you
got to pay it back and at four and a
half percent it's not going to make the
payback that much more exciting either I
just don't think the math even works so
appreciate the call but I I don't know
why people get sucked into these ideas I
I know why they get sucked in who told
him about this I'm sure he saw or he
might have just come up with it on his
own and you know in his mom's basement
but wow the idea it it always rolls back
to the same thing as I'm young I don't
want to fall into the same trap how can
I skirt the process how can I get rich
quick I don't want to I don't want to be
and I hear the slot I don't want to wait
till I'm 60 To Be A Millionaire and in
his case he's a young guy he's going to
be if he does it right he'll be a
millionaire far far far before 60 or 55
or even 50 if he plays his cards right
we have people stand on that debt-free
stage every day Ken and they come in
they're 47 years old they're debt free
baby steps millionaires 45 years old 30
years old we see it all the time look at
George
yeah this cat I don't know how old
George is he can't be a day over 33. hmm
George is gonna look that way when he's
90. I mean I'm just saying maybe he's
three who knows he I don't George is a
young guy I'm just saying it's possible
and it's completely boring
it's not this like sexy thing like he's
like oh I'm taking this money and I'm
moving it over here getting four percent
then I'm moving no it's like just take
your income invest it in good mutual
funds over time let the compound
interest do its work and it ain't
nothing flashy to talk about you look up
and before you know it you know what you
have
money peace Monty yes like peace no debt
it's fun yeah the four and a half
percent is nothing to get excited about
either bro that's not even inflation
that's not you're not gonna get rich on
four and a half percent 4.5 that's a
terrible score in the Olympics it's a
terrible terrible grade on a quiz I mean
4.5 oh yeah nobody gets excited about
4.5 in any area of life and with debt I
don't know
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
their wash and guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by the incomparable
The Fabulous Jade warshaw ladies and
gentlemen triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five I can record that
after the show and you could just make
that a ringtone or something or
announcement when you walk into the
house yes that's what I need here she is
teaching Hill
speaker yes uh Sam warshaw her husband
is in the uh the lobby uh by the way
made a special guest appearance on the
Ramsey show a little earlier today if
you want to check that out uh and uh
we're going to talk about romance scams
and I gotta tell you when I saw the show
run down today I thought maybe I maybe I
had gotten a a scam email look at what
and I look at it and this is what I saw
there's been some headlines in the news
some of you have seen these headlines
here's a few
in love with a scammer Local woman loses
000 wow Iowan says he was robbed of 232
000 in cryptocurrency Romance scale I
got questions that's like a lifetime
movie I don't know that you can say
cryptocurrency and romance in the same
sentence I got questions uh and here's
another headline match group removes 44
spam accounts every minute and then this
is crazy I'd laugh if it wasn't so sad
in 2022 nearly 70 000 people reported a
romance scam and reported losses hit a
staggering 1.3
billion dollars the median reported lost
forty four hundred dollars and only 15
percent of scams are reported
so we actually took a call on the Ramsey
Show recently where a man called in
whose wife was scammed in an online
romance scam not with him oh man she
ended up taking out loans for
um 40
000 so wow that's a quick snapshot of
something I had not heard of until early
this morning romance scams and in
today's world it's very easy to get
scammed on a lot of things but now
yes thieves are preying on people's
hearts Jade what is happening with the
world you got to be careful out there we
can't we can't get desperate we can't
get too thirsty because then the next
thing we know we're going to be scammed
out of forty thousand hundred thousand
dollars I saw this one come through
yesterday
um it was part of a media thing and it
said I'm a mom of three who lost my
entire 401k to a scammer I met on Tinder
oh boy a Tinder swindler uh oh that
feels like a Netflix special it is it is
oh it is so here's here's how it goes
her name is Rebecca Holloway she lost a
hundred thousand dollars to a cruel
romance scam and they call this this is
what they call it Pig butchering oh my
God that's the that's the it's like the
show just got R-rated what are we
talking about it's why is that the term
now that part we know I James was trying
James was explaining it to me it says
she's the third victim to come forward
in recent months about this cruel scam
it's known as Pig butchering whereby
victims are effectively fattened up oh
boy because here's the thing these
relationships online this is not just
like okay I slid into your DMs and we've
been talking for two weeks give me a
hundred thousand no they go they fatten
you up with a lot six months they're in
this for the Long Haul to make sure you
believe it I got a new term flattery
fattery flattery fattery that's what's
happening I don't know if you can even
say that I just made it up that's right
they get they fatten these women up oh
boy careful a lot of I'm saying with
like flattery and like I'm glad you're
reporting on this story look I can say
it because I get it now here's here's
the thing over time and a lot of times
they call they refer to these guys as
Fred's it's like Fred from France that's
crazy he comes in with his
hey big Spinda and he's got his money
and he's that's your French accent I
like that that's my I don't know what
that was but Freaky Fred is who that was
fattening these ladies this whole thing
is out of control so what they do they a
lot of times they prey on at least this
this article says they're looking for
it's a lot of times women who are
recently divorced maybe they've come
into some money and um it says officials
say that this is exploding across the
U.S even the Secret Service is involved
and they're admitting that they're
seeing like a ton of cases here so
here's what we really want to talk so
you get the idea basically what's
happening is these women they're meeting
guys online and the guy seems too good
to be true and they're so enamored by
that that they and honestly and I don't
mean you know a lot of times I think
these women are just so like oh wow he's
interested in me like this is great like
he's got money I've got money and I
think that they're preying on that
mindset and over time once trust is
built it's hey you should be doing what
I'm doing I've got this cryptocurrency
and they will send a link and it looks
like a real account it looks like a real
cryptocurrency it looks like a real
investment account and these women are
transferring the money in and here's so
here's the part that I want you to hear
sight unseen
these are men that you've not ever seen
or been able to reach out and touch yeah
in real life they're just ah
look okay and what do we call what is
that catfishing catfishing I learned
that a couple years ago yeah we don't
know who's behind the screen
um but the fact is these women are
giving money so let's can talk about
just what I'm gonna call you know well
there's two things all right first of
all we'll teach you some investing here
in a second all right but let's just not
get into online relationships let's stop
that but wait Ken because some folks
that's where people meet sometimes I
know okay let me clarify thank you for
clarifying I mean your entire
relationship isn't online yeah you got
to meet the dude needs some skin in the
game before he's asking for some dough
yeah can we meet at Five Guys can we
meet on flowers yeah and a burger at
least yeah that's what I mean well when
it the they're real it's got to be real
so stop this nonsense the girl in the
video in the article she says we
facetimed but he kept finding way it was
hard for me to get a picture of his face
he kept stepping away or being full for
the camera there's your sign here's my
point if he doesn't want to take you out
on a date and spend his money on you
okay then we're not continuing the
conversation I just had to get that out
of myself you are not that lonely you
were not that desperate I need to know
lay my eyes on your face right in real
life right and then don't invest with
anybody like that you need a smart
investor Pro yeah these are men and
women that we trust uh they have been in
the business they are winning in the
business for people and they have the
heart of a teacher we vet them because
we say look if we're going to allow
people to uh come and and know about you
in your area and they meet with you
you've got to take good care of them and
if you look at the facts about real
investing all right not scams online get
rich quick schemes if you invest uh 100
invest 100 a month from 25 to 65 you're
gonna have around one million dollars
for retirement that's not a scam that's
not too good to be true that's based on
the long-term average return of the S P
500 folks real facts real numbers
so a huge protector predictor of
investing success is not the rate of
return but that you actually invest and
you stay with it this is not get rich
quick you need a pro in your corner so
that
they can answer your questions to the
point that you understand everything and
you don't have them tell you what to do
okay you tell them what to do with your
money because you now understand how it
works no Shady face times no catfish
strategies real people real strategies
we can connect you to a far to a Smart
investor Pro and they'll meet maybe
they'll meet with you face to face yeah
they eat sleep and breathe Investments
and they'll take time to work with you
go to ramseysolutions.com smart investor
that's ramseysolutions.com smart
investor I gotta tell you
it I'm shocked at the numbers we just
shared but at the same time
when you don't know
who you are what you're about
what money strategies really work it's
not just their hearts that are being
scammed their brains are being scammed
well that's what she says in here it's
both that's what she says in the article
she was like I feel like my like
psychologically I was
scammed there's no question but if you
don't understand money someone can
manipulate you that way and that's what
we're about here we want you to
understand how money Works how you can
take control of your money and how you
can make it work for you yeah it should
never be complicated and it should never
just be oh do this one thing one time
and then boom collect a big check yeah
don't give anybody money on the internet
period nowhere not on Instagram Facebook
Tinder Tick Tock none of them don't give
them money yeah not the romancer not the
Nigerian prince nobody don't give
anybody all right tindler swindler
this is scary stuff folks well we're
here for you don't move more the show
and your calls coming up this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me in studio
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Phoenix Arizona where Cam awaits
cam how can we help
hey so me and my wife are both 22. she
just graduated I have a year left and we
have no debt of fully funded six-month
emergency fund and then we just have 15K
just sitting in our bank and we're
wondering what route should we go with
this money and what should we look to do
with it ding ding that's exciting
so you guys are coming out of school no
debt you've got the fully funded
emergency fund
um what's the what's the marriage plan
you're not married
no you are married okay I don't know why
sorry I missed that little point so are
you guys interested in home ownership
yeah that is one thing we just don't
know if that's good right now or what we
should do in the next one year or so
with that money
I mean it really it's up to you guys
sitting down and talking about what your
goals are you know logically when we
think about money typically you get
married paying off your debt you're
setting yourself up and depending on
what your lifestyle of choices a lot of
folks do look into Home Ownership
um simply because they want a place to
live and they want to build wealth and
they know that that is a key component
over time of Building Wealth so I do
think that's something to import
important to consider on down the line
but if you guys are the type where
you're like hey we want a backpack
across Europe or we want to do all these
other things I mean tell me a little bit
about what you guys see for the future
even just the next five years
yeah I would say getting into Home
Ownership is the biggest thing and
trying to maybe get one maybe a rental
property or something like that
um I was just so I've been I was just
curious with so if we make about like
65k right now and then when I graduate
it'll be a little bit over 100 together
you're saying just save and look into
the housing market yeah I like that now
if you're interested in real estate like
as rent as you know landlords I would
suggest that you get into real estate
first with a primary residence so then
you kind of understand okay this is what
homeownership looks like this is what
repairs look like this is what you know
I can expect and I feel like that's a
great way to get your feet wet and then
over time you know you could pay up you
know save up and pay cash for a rental
after your primary residence is paid off
that's the way that we would suggest
doing it so I mean year 22 the world is
your oyster you've got plenty of time it
sounds like right now you're just kind
of in a dreaming stage like what what
could we do you know when I graduate we
could do this we could do that and I
would say A1 is keep that 15K keep it
liquid I would not invest it if you're
interested at you know in purchasing a
house in the next five years and just
keep adding to it keep saving up and
keep being intentional so that if the
the time is right you can pull the
trigger and yeah yeah there's an old
phrase I don't know if you're young too
young to remember this my mom and dad
used to say don't let that money burn a
hole in your pocket they give you like
50 cents or something okay and what that
meant was is you know don't be in a
hurry to spend it and I think in this
case the 15 000 I don't think you have
to do much of anything with the 15 I
would build it build build build build
walk through the baby steps and I mean
again the reason we have a baby steps is
because that's where where you guys are
headed and it's going to get you through
the Journey and so I would just stack
cash I don't think enough young couples
realize how valuable it is to stack cash
don't rush into Home Ownership that's
right you just don't need to but
stacking cash gives you options and I
think Jade you nailed that so that's
really good advice cam thank you so much
for the call and for listening watching
the program Michael's up in West Palm
Beach Florida I love me some West Palm
I'm going to tell you that right now
Michael how can we help
hey guys how's it going
um my wife and I are actually recently
married congratulations
can we just hit the four month March oh
my gosh come on somebody you're still in
you're still in la la land man you don't
even know what it's like to be married
yet it's still early I know I think
that's probably true I know it is
so what's going on
together uh my wife and I have about
four hundred thousand dollars in debt
and so that debt is a combination of a
mortgage uh two auto loans personal
loans uh and credit cards can you break
that down
how much is the mortgage
uh 310. okay that makes me feel better
yeah uh tell me it makes me feel better
too those are the two cars what's the
two cars so the two cars are about 45
000 uh then we have about 30 in personal
loans and about 20 in credit cards break
the cars down more uh what are they each
loan and what are they worth
so uh one's twenty thousand one is uh
the other one's twenty five thousand uh
the one the one that's 25 000 we're
probably in pretty good shape on it uh
the other one that's 20 were upside down
by about six thousand how much so if
you're in good shape on 25 what does
that mean
uh I honestly think we could probably
sell it and make about five thousand
okay
interesting okay so now go ahead we our
house so part of what we're trying to
figure out is if we should sell our
house
um and the reason for that is I
purchased the home in 2021 so I've
actually lived in that home for the past
two years as my primary residence okay
um and it's a multi-family home so I've
lived in the front unit and I rented a
room out in it and then the back unit
ran as an Airbnb okay and so the back
unit produced around 30 000 a year okay
um so
what we could do and what we're
contemplating doing is right now the
value of the home is at about 500 000
and that's based on comps in the area so
if we were to sell we would pay off all
debt
um literally all the debt that we have
we would rent however uh renting is a
little more expensive than what our
mortgage would be it is yeah
you don't want to be a landlord or a be
Airbnb person anymore you just want to
live in a normal home with your with
your girl
I I yeah I do want to uh we do want to
just have a house
um now we don't want to be an Airbnb
necessarily but a long-term goal would
be to have some rental properties right
but not this from where you live like
you don't want them in your house
and I do that yeah sell it yeah I'm not
mad at that sell it clear your debt
um look I'm with you I don't want you
know the Joneses living in my in my
basement I I want a a house just just
for myself with my husband so I can
understand that
um you'd be able to clear your debt
you'd rent for a while you'd have a
little bit of money
um left over
to start saving towards you know a down
payment on another house but you could
take your time nothing wrong with
renting by the way
um and and rent till you can accomplish
your goal Sam and I rented for 10 years
okay and look at you now yeah look at us
yeah so I I'm bad at that no absolutely
listen you got to sell the house sell
the house go ahead sell the house
all right I'm writing it down listen no
don't write it down do it I mean listen
brother because Jade is right you clear
all this debt you you take care of a
bunch of mistakes that you guys have
made we're free of that okay and now
she's right you're gonna have leftover
money that you can immediately put into
your uh uh baby step three and then work
on three B baby step three is the three
to six month emergency fund so you get a
head start on the emergency fund while
you're renting and then you're saving up
for 3B and you guys are going to be
you're gonna be everyday millionaires if
you just make this decision now clear
off the debt and make a commitment to
never do it again
and here's the fact we don't usually say
so your house and clear your debt but in
this case it's like well they don't want
this long term well it's a multi-family
home it's really something that was
supposed to be an income property
um that's right so in this case it makes
sense to do but I don't want people
listening going what's the solution just
sell my house and I don't have to go
through this hard you know pain and
heartache that's not what we're saying
at all this is a different type of
situation it is it absolutely is and I'm
excited for you guys uh four months into
to marriage and you guys can be debt
free pretty quick that's an exciting
future it's gonna make learning how to
be married a lot easier I'll tell you
that right now four months they don't
even have bad breath yet okay isn't that
the truth
oh she probably still wears makeup to
bed okay I don't know do they do the
kids do that I don't know your girl
ain't doing that that's a fact all right
folks don't move she's Jade warshaw I'm
Ken Coleman you're listening to the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw is my colleague and co-host of
sour triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our scripture of the day comes from
James 1 12. let me tell you something
anytime I read from James I get a little
I sit upright because he brings it James
for breakfast he brings it blessed is
the one who perseveres under trial
because having said the test that person
will receive the crown of life that the
Lord has promised to those who love him
and our quote from Old Tom Morris the
grandfather of golf Thomas Morris his
name
for True success it matters what our
goals are and it matters how we go about
attaining them the means are as
important as the ends how we get there
is as important as where we go so there
you go good stuff there uh and Jade you
got uh you got something you're pretty
fired up about pretty excited about what
you're just talking about during the
break I got to tell the people when Sam
and I were working to get out of debt
and some of you know 460 000 of debt
there was one component that was like a
silver bullet if you will Ken Coleman
and that is our budgeting and our budget
and in the beginning we started off with
pen and paper you know you're on that
yellow pad going and then Ramsay
Solutions came out with something called
every dollar it was a digital budget
came out in like 2017 and it's still
going and it's better than ever and I've
got to tell people this this is the
missing component this the way every
dollar is these days guys if you had it
before and maybe you know you download
the app and then you never use it go
back into the app I'm telling you I'm
looking directly at you go back into the
app there are so many features there
that are so if you have irregular income
they've got the paycheck planning if you
are trying to look ahead and figure out
how long is it going to take me to pay
off this debt how long is it going to
save me and it take me to save for a
house they've got the the financial Road
mapping plan it will help you it will
change the game for you and so this is
what I want to tell you about I talked
to the guys over there they're like Jade
we're going to structure a deal for
these folks all right oh we got a deal
we got a deal I'm I'm going into my set
it and forget it mode right here you can
sign up today using the code
um that they will put on the screen it's
it's got my name it's a little promo
code or you can find it in the show
notes if you're listening on podcasts
and you're going to get a 14 day free
trial so you can test drive it test it
out see how you like it I can already
tell you you're gonna love it and then
because you signed up you're going to
get 15 off which is a big deal because
the thing the whole thing only costs
what 70 80 bucks 80 bucks so you get 102
off that's a big deal everydollar.com
Jade now that's an easy URL to remember
you wouldn't remember Ken that's why I
promise you everydollar.com slash Jade
and they got a photo of me what am I
looking at it looks like I'm I'm looking
at every dollar you look you know you'll
you'll look it ain't bad you're looking
fast I'm the color of money right there
you got the lime green thing going on
it's fantastic this go guys every dollar
did or use the promo code Jade in our
store to get a digital or physical gift
card all right guys every dollar every
dollar premium that's what you need to
do you heard it here first thank you Ken
fantastic stuff Steven is up now in San
Antonio Texas Stephen how can we help
hey how's it going guys we're having a
blast what's going on with you
uh nothing much I just graduated I'm 22
years old I just graduated from college
congratulations young man nice job thank
you thank you thank you uh my degree's
in finance
um and I've been applying for jobs for
like the last two months now and
yesterday I completed my second
interview out of three for a job
position in Dallas
um
on debt three I've never had any type of
credit cards or anything like that so I
don't have a credit score so when it's
time to start applying for apartments
how how do I qualify or how do I get an
apartment without having any prior like
um credit history or anything like that
so when it comes to getting an apartment
you don't need a credit score to get an
apartment now there might be some
apartments that are you know bozos and
make you have a credit score and you'll
just
brush the dust off your feet and go to
the next apartment right so there's
plenty out there that will allow you to
do that what I would suggest now is
anytime you can have any record of where
you've lived and paid rent so even if
you're living with your parents make
sure that you're paying them something
and that you can keep record that hey
I've been able to pay rent obviously
things like utilities uh anything that
you're paying payments on uh cell phones
those sorts of things save that and keep
record of that because they basically
want to know that you can pay that's
right and here's the you know
at the end of the day sometimes when you
use choose to use cash there is a little
bit of um a premium that comes with that
uh for your freedom which is sometimes
they'll make you do first and last
month's rent or they might you know have
some extra you know double first and
last month's rent because they want to
make sure you have the money even though
your whole life is built on you having
money
um so just be ready for those extra
costs that they might ask you to do but
at the end of the day you are able to
yeah you can and again James Wright we
have a system and that system has been
gamed against us and that's what the
whole credit score is about it's
actually not a score of something you've
done right it's just a function of how
much debt you've had and how much you've
made your payments and so again be okay
to be courageous enough to push back and
go okay listen the reason I don't have
his debt is I'm never going to have debt
and so I'm actually the kind of tenant
you want to have because I'm not going
to be over my skis uh with with too much
debt or any debt and can I show you my
payment in history I'm willing to put
down two months deposit to you know you
know have a conversation because a lot
of these these these apartment companies
their policy are set by somebody way up
the ladder okay yes right and Common
Sense wins the day sometimes yeah uh and
I'm glad Jade told you there will be
some that'll look at you and go I'm
sorry and sorry policy and then you have
to go somewhere else and so somewhere
where they use their brains basically so
do be prepared it's not a it's not a
guarantee uh but also don't be afraid to
to work it a little bit because what do
you have to lose nothing at all yeah Sam
and I were able to get Apartments
several times over and you know it's
like Ken said go somewhere where they're
you know they're actually turning on
their brain and using critical thinking
and for us a lot of times it was like
look here's our here's our payment
history here's our bank stubs look we've
got money in the bank like that sort of
thing so thanks for the call Steve and
excited for you my young friend you're
gonna do great uh let's get we get one
more in here Tim from Saginaw Michigan
how can we help
hi
I have a auto loan that I've been
mandated to pay through a judgment of
divorce and it's at a fairly low rate so
I'm just asking am I better off trying
to pay it down quickly or uh pay it for
the remainder of the time uh you know
and they try to save more in my 401k or
or what would you suggest I always
always always suggest paying off debt as
quickly as possible
okay always
um especially for many reasons in this
case I'm sure there's interest
accumulating which who wants to pay
interest I would rather gain compound
interest later on down the road so I
want to free up as much of my income as
quickly as possible so that later on
like what you were what you mentioned
you can invest more and can do more of
that and um you know what's the how much
do you owe on this car
13-2 and the interest rate is at 2.75
yeah um is it your only debt
yes yeah how quickly do you think you
could knock that out with your income
um I could probably do at least half the
time uh because I have to pay special
support and that type of thing so
um but I could probably knock a couple
years off of it oh yeah yeah I'd say go
gazelle intense which around here that
just means going all out hard in the
paint to get this thing knocked out how
old are you
I am 58. yeah get that thing knocked out
man Tim Jake gave you great financial
advice but I'm gonna give you I think
there's an emotional piece of this
particular situation she's right she's
going to be right every time on why why
you should pay the debt off quicker and
not just play out all the payments but
this is a divorce
and you're 58 and I'd pay this off in
the next year if I could because I want
to remove you already got spousal
payments I want to remove this debt
financially but also emotionally and
move past this my friend I take on a
second job weekend work just to pay this
stupid car off I get mad about it and
then be free of it my friend and the
financial and the emotional benefits are
going to be worth it Jade warshaw great
great hour thanks for being with me and
riding shotgun as always James Childs
our fearless leader in the booth and all
the fellas
and you America we do it for you this is
your show this is the Ramsay show
look if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]